if it's actually like this whole thing
is still [ __ ] with me hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to three
this one's called penumbra and it's just
some whoa
oh okay
oh all right yeah coin all right woohoo
hey wait a minute
this is like penumbra because penumbra
started out in the Arctic and you went
in a hatch to go into a base with like
caves and stuff interesting spooky
oh hello Oh shadow alright you got it
baby thanks for the hint oh my goodness
you that was a great drawing of this
very room well it's a pillar it's a big
old pillar and ooh pardon Oh eat this is
drawing here wait
oh go round and ring around the Rosie Oh
what the hell what wait a minute wait
wait a minute wait a minute
oh okay that's weird
okay that's weird oh hi okay that's
funky ah oh
two times oh oh oh oh oh what whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh okay okay all
right well that was a fun pillar I've
never played a game of war I know
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no what but okay that's fine yeah uh uh
hi hi hey whoa okay no all right don't
run for it I guess
well I don't like that at all that was
not good but I seem to be okay for now
oh no oh wait no hey what hey wait a
minute where am I oh hey oh oh oh okay
this is messed up
this is so weird oh that's a building Oh
God
I thought it was just lights
uh-huh okay I've probably missed some
coins here and there I don't know if
getting coins is like absolutely
mandatory to beating this game but I
have not been getting those okay oh this
weird oh okay all right um go round and
round where where it stops nobody knows
oh that's bright man that hurts my eyes
oh my god okay
oh hey up there how do you do I don't
know if I'm going the right way was a
clockwise or counterclockwise uh why are
my eyes dusty - oh wait what wait what
wait wait what no no no this game does
[ __ ] with me so good this game dicks
me so good how does this game dog know
how's the scheme doing that how are you
doing that it's so well-hidden it's so
well done that's really well done
oh I hate this but okay let's go let's
go baby
Oh doc doc don't shush please don't
shush I don't like this shushing come in
all right I'll leave then
oh go oh I can't go never mind I didn't
want anything I don't want anything
oh hey paint hate hate hate that hi oh
that's not so good um all right well
let's back up then oh wow [ __ ] Oh Oh God
um okay no look II uh no look II god no
look II I guess
oh no look II no look II know what I'm
not looking I would never look look II
is not what I do
I know lucky I've never been look I've
never looked in my life lookin it's
gonna be really hard to go through this
maze if it's just constantly like real
dickish yeah if it's actually like this
whole thing is still [ __ ] with me
I've been my brain ooh 'td all right
well I'm dead oh no I'm live I guess
being in bright lit up areas is the bad
thing oh [ __ ]
okay nope okay let me read this note
again all right I can't see oh and if
you're under something okay it's it's
blind it's not deaf it's blind maybe I
don't know oh no hide under the uh okay
that covered the covers the cover to
cover I can't no you don't anything but
this no okay all right got it
the maze has been solved by my brain
okay I see it already I see it okay all
right I got it
okay there's actually a faint line of
what it's supposed to be anyway so
helpful no no that's right that's right
nope that's unpleasant but this is a
weird change of pace in the game I'm not
sure if I like it too I hate it I hate I
hate are you know
alright never mind I don't want to
complain about the game at all ever
again game is fine game is fine and
dandy it's both fine and so dandy it
really wants to hang around this area
hey well how you doing hey are you doing
cutting it gunning it gonna get gonna
get gonna get gonna get oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're fine baby we're fine we're fine
we're so good oh [ __ ] we're not good
we're not good okay we're good we're
good we're good we're good we're good
we're good
okay um I think I need to go that way
wrap around again and then we're good
then we are good okay no you tricky
can't trick me like that no no don't
come back no no no no this is not the
right way no it is okay this is the
right way man how did I avoid it that
first time cuz I was not doing it right
I was definitely not doing it right okay
straight shot to the end come on I made
it I made I'm going for it whatever that
is I'm going for thank you all that's
children's drawings guiding my path okay
oh all right
runner I know it said the other way but
I want to run around this way just to
see what happens the note goes away for
you that way alright this way round and
round and round I go where I'll stop
nobody knows it's not working maybe it
was this way maybe the drawing was wrong
maybe like I just had some crazy drug
trip down in the basement and I'm just
out in the cold running around a pillar
I'm like guys guys it's crazy this
pillars just it's not just blang kurz
just run around it come on hurry up
you're gonna miss it I'm just a fool
running in a circle forever and ever
until I die of cold
welp I feel real dumb right now I feel
really silly oh I know what I need to
take my clothes off of course
shinier to take all my pants off of
course duh how could I be so smart
ha ha ha gotta take it yeah there we go
all right I don't know what's happening
oh wait the tent wasn't there before
that's what I'm okay all right
[Music]
all right we're out okay I didn't know
how long that was gonna go this one is
called I've already forgotten
this one's called belly literally just
called belly Wow what No
oh this is so weird
am I really in a belly ow
I got hit oh how am I supposed to
reflect all these oh this is so weird
hello buddy
are you oh my god don't shoot your weird
sperm things at me no no no no no no no
none of that oh hi again
what was that oh boy and dead alright
oops sorry
oh boy alright and on the move again I
feel I feel particularly uncomfortable
about this one oh hey buddies hey are
you doing that yeah you doing
also what am i but that that's a whole
other question like what am i some
horrible parasite maybe I shouldn't
maybe there's like the body's immune
system and oh yeah yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ]
oh wow is there an end to this I mean it
said there was a leaderboard oh wait at
the bottom there's like some kind of
progress thing whoa what is that what is
that I don't know what that is okay okay
I have that oh oh [ __ ] oh okay good for
me oh my god oh my god all right there
we go
somehow we're still alive
whoa whoa hey okay wow that was really
weird that was super weird
that was weird okay I think once is
enough for that one no that was a long
progress bar at the bottom and I don't
feel like going through that whole thing
cuz that would take like an hour to get
through that whole bar um okay I for one
am okay this next one is MN MH m dy
productions dim is a completely sound
based experience play with headphones
really and put your system sound as loud
as you can tolerate alright
oh [ __ ] we're in this is a playable demo
for an upcoming horror game the demo
takes place in a small part of a house
where you play as an unnamed protagonist
with a very specific backstory that
makes him know what is going on well him
not you explore the house look for clues
and experience this small ten minutes
playable demo ah good old unnamed
protagonist with a backstory the ball ah
I should probably find that cross first
oh of course
the cross where's the cross we're
getting like Grandma levels of graphics
here Oh
oh god please Oh God
Oh Lord please Lord descend your music
to help me the doors here but it looks
weak maybe I could push through it
okay I don't know why those chains are
undulating like that but alright
hello I'm boosting through it
oh hi okay oh wow this flashlight is
pretty pretty room level
okay alright okay alright okay
Bouck maybe the water but is behind this
door I should find a way in right okay
glad that happened so I got to find a
way to get around the door do I get a
crowbar or something of the like this
tomato superset blood
I see cans there could be tomato soup I
have no idea what's going on a lot of
cigarettes just lying about you do that
you want to run that by me again also
were you there before because I feel
like I would have noticed you Oh where
it belongs where what belongs the ball
you talking about the ball do I need to
go back for the ball
oh the ball is not there anymore where's
the ball go the ball wait wait a minute
alright it's probably fine
hey the ball yeah that's the ball
alright okay I'm gonna I just I've
screwed myself dad's playing some soccer
or football oh now I've gotten it stuck
how's trouble here gettin away from like
the wall you know just
can I please all I want is to get it no
not in this is oh boy the door is
blocked so is the ball huh boy yes they
didn't think this through they did oh my
god they did not think this through
okay here we go we're on a road no now
now now god damn you
okay alright
Oh boom okay and there we go all right
here we go we're on a roll this time
this time we're gonna get this nope
Oh what
hello oh it's open okay I was close to
the parcel credit
oh hey how you doing [ __ ] hell all
right cool that's fine no water here no
water here I sure am thirsty just got a
hankering for some some water just need
a little bit of water just a slight
sloosh of water please
a little bit a splish great the
generator went down that is great I
wouldn't have thought that a place this
decrepit would need a generator oh okay
that's that's probably fine
where's the generator by the way I never
knew that so you want to run that by me
again also is this my house cause if it
is I have many concerns about you know
you you sack of [ __ ] oh you think that's
gonna scare me no no I can do that too
yeah it's practically the same all right
well I don't know where the generator is
but uh doesn't seem to be here so I
guess I'm just gonna go back and forth
until it shows me what it wants me to
see so you know I'm gonna do that who is
this new you're not going anywhere you
know that right get rid of the stupid
cross don't make me angry
oh all right well now I'm okay oh [ __ ]
Hey well whoa hey hey
don't like that okay that's the end of
it under Suman Mundi game there's a
glimpse of our final product honestly
not bad but just a little oh just a
little unpolished like there those
scares they got me good but overall I
didn't take the whole game like the
whole game from the get-go didn't get
like get me immersed into it in a
serious way it just seemed very it's
it's it's not that it wasn't serious or
anything like that it's just like the
game itself didn't lead me to really buy
into it because it was just a bit too
unfocused do you know what I mean anyway
I don't have too many criticisms about
the game it was fine it scared me and is
good with more polish it will go a long
way so it just needs a bit more polish
so not bad not bad
that was three scary games very scary
very fun I appreciate it a lot and I
appreciate you guys being here to watch
along so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other scare games
that I played in the link in the
description below to the scary games
playlist and as always I'll see you
[Music]